welcome to the kill test you ready got
the head off
you'll kill
the vajra mushti
originating in India the vasha mushti is
an edge knuckle duster the unique design
features sharpened blades on every side
of the handle making it a specialty
weapon only wielded by well-trained
indian warriors the sharp edges on all
sides provided the user with a wide
range of lethal attacks from deadly
stabs and slashes to devastating punches
a traditional Indian martial art where
the weapon is tied to the fists of
wrestlers has lineage dating back to the
Middle Ages and is still practiced today
by professional wrestlers in India using
non-lethal knuckle dusters
blade Smiths welcome to the kill test to
find out what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do I will take your weapon
to deliver multiple lethal blows on this
ballistics dummy
Kyle York first you ready oh yeah
wow
all right Kyle let's talk about your
weapon here I was worried about the
finger Wells that you had there that
they would be an issue especially when
I'm punching no issues there I like the
fact that my acid gets slippery it gave
me a very good grip overall it is a
beautiful piece and your weapon
will kill oh yeah all right Ben your
turn sir are you ready ready let's do
this
foreign
[Music]
here
the edges are very sharp but there are
some sharp edges that you have in here
every movement started to give me a
little bruise and cut off some skin
right there but in terms of what this
weapon will do
it will kill thanks Doug my hand
all right please welcome to the strength
test
strength and durability of your vajra
mushties as well as their overall
construction and I'll be stabbing and
punching into this sheet metal and chain
guy you're up first you ready for this
yep
foreign
test your two long blades held up great
the center blade here took some chipping
on that chain I'm looking at the Grain
in there and it's it's pretty big I
would have liked to have seen that
refined but in general these two blades
held up well nice job awesome thanks Ben
all right Ben you're up you ready for
this sure am
foreign
[Music]
well the first thing I feel when I
picked this weapon up is it's sheer Mass
I mean it's a heavy heavy weapon that
did you some justice in the strength
test the only thing I could see is a
little bit of glinting on the lower
blade but the middle blade it took a
pretty major deflection right here it
kind of cracked one more little little
hit here and that would just come off
the main thing working against you on
this blade is the rough inner surface I
couldn't really find a real comfortable
way of getting this finger out of Harm's
Way but after the strength test is all
in one piece nice job thank you
all right bleeds bits we know your
weapons can heal and we know they are
strong now it's time to find out just
how sharp they are to find out it'll
take your weapons and deliver some stabs
and slices on these spice bags Kylie up
first you ready for this yep let's do
this
[Music]
foreign
let's talk about your weapon it is
comfortable it's a good fit on my hand
it's got a pointy enough tip over there
but with that one piece where you're
missing some edges it was more of a
jagged cut when it came to stabbing and
slashing on both weapons on each end
it'll cut good job thank you Doug
Ben your turs are you ready ready let's
go let's do it
foreign
the weight that you have here back up
the cut because you have very sharp
edges and the cuts are very deep but my
hand when I'm making impact still rubs
on the inside of your handle but other
than that sir your Beast
yeah we'll cut thanks Doug
all right guys you guys both came
through with unbelievable pieces of work
unfortunately we can only send one of
you guys home with the title of Fortune
fire champion and a check for ten
thousand dollars and our champion today
is
Kyle congratulations Ben unfortunately
you're not walking home to Champion
today the time has come and have to ask
you to leave the fourth floor all right
thank you guys this was awesome for sure
Kyle amazing job
I busted my butt and honestly did the
best that I could so I don't have any
regrets
well Kyle congratulations you will be
leaving here with the title Forge and
fire champion and a check for ten
thousand dollars congratulations thank
you my wife's gonna be super pumped when
I tell her that I'm the next forest fire
champion
what are you gonna do with that cash man
my wife and I are probably going to use
it for a down payment on a house that's
cool absolutely fantastic cool 18 months
ago I would have never imagined being
here today hell yeah I'm forged and fire
champion
laughs
the dehome machete
this lethal machete was once wielded by
the legendary all-female Army in Western
Africa known as the dahome Amazons the
long slightly curved blade flared out to
a wide tip giving the female warriors
the ability to deliver fatal blows that
cut clean through bone and flesh in a
single blow these skilled women warriors
were an elite fighting force and
extremely intimidating often carrying
trophies of their fallen enemies the
machetes were a powerful weapon designed
to cleave through anything that got in
their way today the dahome machete can
be seen wielded in the 2020 HBO series
Lovecraft country
datefits welcome to the kill test
I will take your machete and deliver
some lethal blows on this ballistics
dummy
Alex you're first you ready for this yes
sir
I'm most concerned about everything with
this test I'm not sure it's sharp enough
I'm not sure it's strong enough I don't
know what it's going to do to my plate I
have no idea
foreign
Alex the bounce you have your blade is
nice for every cut I can really control
and see that I'm chopping in there the
edge no issues at all it is still very
sharp more importantly sir your machete
it will kill thanks
all right Adam it's time to have fun
with your blade are you ready sir yes
sir
my blade doesn't break I had a lot of
setbacks making this blade you know I
had to start over I hope it doesn't come
back to bite me in the buck saying a
little prayer please don't break please
don't break please don't break
[Music]
thank you
yes
all right now I'm just talking about
your weapon here this is a very forward
heavy blade but that forward weight
really Cuts deep into this ballistics
dummy overall sir
it will keel
that's worth it right there I go home
now
all right gentlemen you know what time
it is it's time for the strength test
the shield chop
what I want to see on top of how durable
your blades are is their effectiveness
against that Shield all right so Alex
you're up first you ready yes sir
thank you
all right so Alex obviously there's a
bit of an issue what happened here is
you can you can see the grain size it
looks like 40 grit sandpaper which is
really really large grain and then right
here
is that black yeah that was a crack okay
so that crack existed probably during
the heat treat once I hit
face onto the shield it just cut loose
Alex we hate to see that your blade had
a catastrophic failure but you are not
out of the fight just yet your blade
broke on the fourth strike so that means
Adam in order to become Fortune fire
Champion you're to homie machete must
survive four strikes you ready yes
everything is riding on these four
strikes I need my machete to hold
together I've got to make it through
this
foreign
you survived your four strikes that
means you are the forge of fire Champion
so congratulations
Alex unfortunately you didn't win this
round you crush it in round one round
two but your time in the Forge has ended
I'm gonna have to ask you to please step
off the fourth floor
thanks I'm a little disappointed but I'm
definitely proud of the machete that I
made making something this big was quite
a challenge it's a learning process so
I'm definitely glad I had this
opportunity I'm glad I got to know all
these other Smiths this was fun it was
it was a blast
well Adam your blade survived the four
strikes It's A Beautiful Beast and it
just won you ten thousand dollars in the
title of Forge and fire Champion
congratulations man
well done is it everything you thought
it would be and more it's been an honor
been a pleasure wow what an experience
it's kind of surreal but it's a great
feeling it's awesome my family supported
me so kids we're going to Disney
foreign
the Mesopotamian sickle sword
the sickle sword originated in
Mesopotamia at the height of the Bronze
Age around 2500 BC
these sickle and curved shaped swords
often symbolized royalty and power and
were primarily wielded during ceremonies
by Kings and authority figures although
these swords were not common on the
battlefield the belly of the blade
allowed for quick devastating blows and
inspired designs for later weapons such
as the deadly Egyptian kopech
bladesmiths welcome to the kill test
find out what kind of lethal damage they
will do I'm gonna take your weapons
deliver some lethal blows of this
ballistics dummy
take a beer first you ready cut the head
off let's do that
foreign
Jacob let's talk about your sickle sword
right here your Edge is razor sharp
coupled with the fact that this is a
very light weapon I can use velocity to
really wield that sharp edge it cuts
deep into this ballistics dummy and
overall sir your weapon
little Keel thank you
all right Robert your turn sir you ready
I'm ready let's do this
foreign
sickle sword it's a very light blade
that much lighter than the other one and
the angle that you have in here lends
itself to use not only velocity but the
sharpness of your Edge to cut very deep
into this ballistics dummy an overall
sir
you will kill thank you
[Music]
played Smiths welcome to the strength
test the armored Warrior chop test the
strength and overall durability of your
Mesopotamian sickle sword I'm going to
be chopping into these armored Warriors
chicken beer up first you ready for this
I don't think I get a choice you don't
have a choice
thank you
what actually happened is your sword bit
into the other sword by about 3 16 of an
inch and it took out this chip and once
that chip was gone the hole so it blew
up
your grain looks good
but unfortunately uh it's just this
sword against that sword this time that
sword won yep
all right Jacob we hate to see this
happen you gave us a beautiful blade but
unfortunately it did suffer catastrophic
failure on the seventh strike but you
were not out of the fight yet because
Robert in order to become the champion
you will have to survive every single
one of those seven strikes on the
armored Warrior are you ready let's roll
the dice all right Ben
good job
well Robert the big thing is it's one
sword nice job thank you
well Robert you made it through all the
testing Jacob it's a beautiful piece of
work unfortunately due to your
catastrophic failure we cannot continue
testing and for that reason I'm gonna
have to ask you to please step off the
forge floor I think gentlemen it was an
honor thank you very much very nice job
thank you
uh you know it totally sucks but I
really am proud of the blade I made
either way you know they said pretty
much nothing but good things about it up
until it broke and well I totally come
back for this and maybe get a shot at
making it all the way through
well Robert we never like to see
competitors blades break but yours did
not and that makes you the newest Forge
and fire Champion you just got yourself
a check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations thanks thanks
feel pretty good crazy dude crazy
yeah winning this Championship I think
has really pushed me to my limits and
then that makes me want to push them
even more now I'm a champion I'm going
to go ahead and get my abs Smith
membership and just really refine my
skills
[Music]
oh
this is the elephant tusk sword
dating as far back as the 6th Century BC
the mighty elephant was used during
Warfare often armed with the fierce
elephant tusk sword this Lethal Weapon
featured a socket that connected
directly to the elephant's Tusk the
double-edged blade was designed to
inflict massive destruction as an
elephant charged through barricades and
ranks of enemy soldiers throughout
history there is evidence of thousands
of elephant tusk swords being used in
battle however only four pairs of these
intimidating weapons still exist today
blade Smiths welcome to the Keel test in
battle these swords were attachu
elephants who just rammed across its
opponents find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do we're gonna
go Hog Wild on this ballistics dummy
Salem you're up first you ready for this
hell yeah let's do this
oh
I wasn't expecting his head to come off
all right James talk about your weapon
here
every thrust was deadly it went all the
way through what I do like is I can see
the Damascus pattern on your blade there
Jaden your elephant tusk sword it will
kill
that's all I wanted all right Matt your
turn sir you ready hopefully my store is
not irrelevant after this test
we're gonna have fun
right there
all right Matt it penetrates very deep
and on the way out it cuts its weighted
weapon right here that when it thrusts
see the hole right in the middle of the
ballistics dummy it destroyed everything
in there your weapon right here it will
kill thank you Doug
all right gentlemen the strength test
we've mounted your elephant test swords
on our battering ram here and I will be
attacking that armored Soldier
all right Jaden you ready for this yeah
let's do it okay
[Music]
that's terrifying
Jayden I really have to commend you on
the Artistry of this play the low layer
pattern really pops the connections here
are all really beautifully done
and for this test that tip still has an
edge everything is right and tight and
true and nothing's changed
well done thank you Matt you ready to
roll absolutely okay
[Music]
so Matt your blade held up fine the tip
it's a little bit duller than what it
started out with but I wouldn't run my
finger down this Edge so nicely done it
held up beautifully thank you
all right blade Smith we know your
weapons can kill and we know they are
strong now it's time to find out how
sharp your weapons are this is the
sharpness test the guillotine fruit
slice
I'm gonna take your Allison tusks Sword
release it and try to cut through the
fruit I want to see Clean Cuts all the
way through
getting you up first you ready oh yeah
all right let's do this
thank you
nice
all right Gene your edge here cut all
the way through cleanly bottom line sir
your elephant tusk sword you'll look up
all right Matt your turn sir you ready
I'm ready
all right now let's talk about your
weapon here the weight on this it drives
the cut all the way through your Edge is
sharp more importantly sir
you'll come thank you Doug
well Jayden Matt you guys both perform
exceptionally well during your tests but
as you know only one of you guys will be
leaving here with the title of Fortune
fire champion and today's Fortune fire
Champion is
Jayden congratulations you won man Matt
unfortunately that means you did not
come out on top today I'm gonna have to
ask you to please step out
I'm proud of the sword that I've turned
in they were virtually the same
performance which I mean yeah you too
and Jaden's weapon he turned in a work
of art and I think he deserves the title
first thing I'm going to do when I get
home kiss my wife and crack open a beer
well Jaden that means you are today's
Forge and fire Champion you're gonna be
leaving here with a check for ten
thousand dollars man congratulations
thank you
I'm the new storage and fire champion
and I'm really stoked about it how old
are you again 19 19 years old that is
extremely impressive man thank you what
I'm so bad at emotion
foreign
one of the most notorious rulers in
history Genghis Khan and his Mongolian
Army conquered the Asian continent
through terrifying land seizures
throughout the 13th century Khan and his
troops used the slightly curved sword to
inflict deep and lethal attacks during
horse raids killing tens of millions of
people in their path
this brutal single-edged blade was
lightweight for sustained mounted combat
while the razor sharp edge easily
decapitated prisoners which was often
the tactic used when seizing new
territory having established the Mongol
Empire one of the largest land Empires
to date Genghis Khan remains one of the
most prolific rulers in history
alright bladesmiths welcome to the kill
test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do I will take your
sword and deliver some killing blows to
this for the six dummy Peter York first
you ready yes sir let's do this
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Peter first stop your Edge is sharp the
balance feels good but it did take quite
a pronounced Bend but more important
thing is
it'll kill
I timed that perfectly
right doc Everett are you ready sir
let's do some surgery
[Music]
yikes
all right everyone your Edge is very
sharp it slashes nicely your tip
punctures easily cuts on the way out
with all these cuts
it'll appeal
[Music]
tournament it's time for the strength
test
now to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades I'll be
attacking our armored targets over here
Beauty up first you ready
let her rip Tater chip
[Music]
all right Peter um
I'm gonna start with your handle I find
it really comfortable the way it flares
towards the tip works pretty good for my
hand and I love what you did with this
kind of low layer count Damascus it's
very dramatic but
we've got some
very deep roles
on this Edge
there you go
here
those chips that's an issue but all in
all a good job
all right Everett you ready I am okay
yeah piece of armor
let's see
all right Everett your blade still spot
on what I really like is the fact that
that blade is
at its widest point maybe 3 16 of an
inch
you don't need weight and mass for
strength in a properly tempered blade
that's really good you've got a section
of Blade here that's not quite as sharp
as it was right there all in all I think
you did a great job awesome
all right blade Smith this is the war
batter slice
the test is the sharpness of your blade
I will take your weapon and slash across
these War banners
Peter you're up first you ready yes sir
let's do this
foreign
so where your Edge has a chip you can
see it catches and rips through the
banner where it's not it cuts nicely
overall sir it will cut
all right ever it's your turn you ready
sir I think this beats the hell out of
peer review all right let's find out
foreign
your edge here does cut it's sharp it
cuts in some of the areas on some parts
of it it ripped but overall sir
it'll cut awesome
all right gentlemen based on what we've
seen in the weapons test the judges have
made their final decision about which
view is our next forest and fire
champion
Peter
Peter your sword took the most damage in
our strength test you had a rolled Edge
and your blade bent for that reason I
have to dismiss you from the forge I may
not be the forged and fire Champion but
I still think I'm a badass myth
well Everett your blade is comfortable
well-balanced strong and deadly and that
makes you the forest and fire champion
and that's a title that comes with a
check for 10 grand good job come on
forward and Shake our hands
this experience was really fun it was
really tough in a lot of places and it's
been a hell of a ride